[Music]
Christian.
food music.
Hello. Hello everyone. My name is Jared.
My pronouns are he, they, and I am here
to welcome you to this lovely place
called the table. We are so glad you are
here tonight. Um, thanks for joining us.
Hello online friends. Thank you for
joining us as well. We like to see you
even though I can't. Um, I know you're
there. Um, and that makes me happy. So,
um, announcements
coming up September 21st.
Um, am I is it just me imagining my
voice is weird or is am I really loud?
Okay, wonderful. Um, September 21st,
back to announcements. And now that my
add is kicked in, um, there's going to
be a status state of the table status of
the table state of the table meeting at
400 p.m. right here. That'll be before
service on September 21st. And if you're
wondering, Jared, what is a state of the
table meeting? It's where the leadership
gets up and tells us what's going on. We
do not talk about the price of Windex or
anything that it costs to actually run
the church. We will talk about the
finances, but there will be no arguments
about anything. Um, it will be a lovely
time of discussion and awareness. So,
please join us and find out what's going
on cuz they're going to talk about the
next 6 months. So, if you're doing the
math on that, that gets you to like
March on what's going on. So, through
the holiday season. Um but we'd love to
hear you uh or have you come and show up
and participate. So with that um I would
like to remind you that we've lit these
candles um
in our worship time as a uh sign of the
presence of Christ among us both feel
fully divine and human.
And we will exit the kingdom of noise,
hurry and productivity.
Now we enter the kingdom of silence,
stillness and simplicity.
sacred space, a place for prayer,
worship, and adoration.
A place to behold Christ, revelation of
God, heartbeat of creation.
Allow the unforced rhythms of grace to
find you, to mend your heart.
May we all come home.
>> Thank you, Jared. If you guys want to
stand with us, we're going to get
started with some music tonight. And um
if you are new to the table, I just
wanted to go ahead and introduce the
people that are in front of you tonight.
So Jesse is playing on guitar and Maggie
is on keys. She is my twin. So you're
not seeing double and Nate is on drums.
And we are just people. So um we hope
that you will join in and sing with us,
that you'll lift your voices, follow
Finley's lead. He loves the music and
he's always lifting up the shout of
praise so you can join in with him. But
um I just wanted to like take away any
barrier that's between our ability as a
community to enter into this worship. Um
because it's not a performance and it's
not a concert. It is truly a moment
where we get to engage this creative
space together and hopefully interact
with this spirit of love and and divine
beauty and um forgiveness and grace um
that we find in Jesus. So I just invite
each one of you into that space with us
tonight as we sing. And Jesse's going to
get us started on Graves in the Garden.
So you guys follow him.
[Music]
And I searched the world,
but it couldn't fill me.
A man's empty praise and treasures of
faith were never enough.
You came along
and put me back together.
And every desire is now satisfied
here in your love.
Oh, there's nothing
better than you. Oh, there's nothing
better than you. Oh, there's nothing.
Nothing is better than you.
[Music]
And I'm not afraid
to show you my weakness,
my failures and flaws. Lord, you've seen
them all and you still call me friend.
[Music]
Cuz the God of the mountain
is the God of the valley.
[Music]
There's not a place your mercy and grace
won't find me again.
Oh, there's nothing
better than you. Oh, there's nothing
nothing is better than you.
Oh, there's nothing
better than you. Oh, there's nothing
nothing is better than you.
[Music]
You turn morning to dancing.
You give beauty for ashes.
You turn shame into glory.
You're the only one who can.
You turn gra into garden.
You turn into harmonies.
You turn seas into.
You're the only one who can.
Oh, there's nothing
better than you. Oh, there's nothing
nothing is better than you.
[Music]
Oh, there's nothing
better than you. Oh, there's nothing
nothing is better than you.
[Music]
>> All right, kiddos. You guys are
dismissed to go to your classes and your
teachers will meet you over by the doors
and lead you back there.
Thank you, kids ministry team, for
serving our kiddos and loving on them.
Y'all have fun.
[Music]
No, maybe.
All right, we're going to transition
into the prayers of the people. Um, you
can read along on the screens and speak
the parts that are in word out uh in red
out loud together. Um and then we'll
open up space in the middle for you to
share a name or a situation that's on
your heart and then we'll close out the
prayer together again.
Jesus, for this city of Sax, Texas, and
for every city and community and all who
live in them, we pray to you for the
good earth you have given us and the
wisdom and the will to conserve it. We
pray to you for the old and the sick,
for the widow and orphan, for the
injured and suffering. We pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed, the
unemployed and destitute, for prisoners
and captives and all who remember and
care for them. We pray to you for the
vulnerable, the marginalized, and those
unjustly targeted for their gender,
sexuality, race, or other perceived
difference. We pray to you for those
experiencing loss, loneliness, and
disconnection. And for those struggling
with mental and emotional health, we
pray to you, Lord. We know that you love
us and that you hear us. So, we lift
these names and situations up to you.
[Music]
Just
for the names and moments that we've
spoken aloud and for those that we have
kept in our hearts. We pray to you that
they may have life and light, healing
and hope, peace and a deep sense of your
presence. Amen.
We will feast in the house of Zion.
We will sing with our hearts restored.
He has done great things. We will say
together
we will feast and weep no more.
We will not be burned
by the fire.
He is the Lord our God.
We are not consumed
by the blood
of hell protected.
We will feast in the house of Zion.
We will sing with our hearts restored.
He has done great things. Little say
together
we will feast and we no more
in the dark of night
before the dawn.
My soul be not afraid
for the promised morning.
Oh, how long?
Oh God of Jacob,
be my strength.
We will feast in the house of Zion.
We will see with our hearts restored.
He has done great plain things. We will
say to together
we will feast and we know more
[Music]
no more.
[Applause]
Oo,
no more
no more.
[Music]
Every bow brokeen
and betrayed.
You are the faithful
one.
And from the garden
to the grave,
bind us together.
Bring shalom.
We will feast in the house of Zion.
We will sing with our hearts restored.
He has done great things. We will say
together
we will feast and we know more.
Oh
no.
[Applause]
Oh
no more.
[Applause]
Oh
no.
[Music]
In Luke 12 it says, "Then Jesus told his
disciples, therefore I tell you, don't
worry about your life, what you'll eat,
about your body, what you'll wear. Life
is more than food, and the body is more
than clothes. Consider the ravens. They
don't sew or reap. They have no
storehouse or barn. Yet God feeds them.
And how much more valuable are you than
birds?
Who by worrying can add an hour to his
life? Since you can't do this in very
little things, why do you worry about
the rest? Consider how the liies grow.
They don't labor or spin. Yet I tell
you, not even Solomon in all his
splendor was dressed like one of these.
If that is how God clothed the grass of
the field which is here today and
tomorrow is thrown into the fire, how
much more will he clothe you, oh you of
little faith.
I'll never be more loved than I am right
now. Wasn't holding you up. So there's
nothing I can do to let you down.
It doesn't take a trophy
to make you proud.
I'll never be more love than I am right
now.
>> Going through a storm, but I won't go
down. I hear your voice carried in the
rhythm of the wind to pull me down.
You would cross the ocean
so I wouldn't drown.
You've never been closer than you are
right now.
[Music]
You are enough.
You are enough
and I will be content
in every circumstance.
[Music]
You are enough
forever enough. Always enough. More than
enough.
Yeah. Forever enough. Always enough.
More than enough.
[Music]
I don't want to forget
how I feel right now. On the mountain
top. I can see so clear what it's all
about.
Stay by my side when the sun goes down.
I want to forget how I feel right now.
[Music]
You are enough.
I will be content
in every circumstance.
Gyra,
you are enough.
Forever enough, always enough. More than
enough.
Forever enough. Always enough. More than
I'm already love.
I'm already chosen.
I know who I am.
I know what you've spoken.
I'm already love
more than I could imagine.
And that is love.
[Music]
Oh, I'm already love.
I'm already chosen.
I know who I am.
I know what you've spoken.
I'm already love
more than I can imagine.
And that is enough.
I'm already love.
I'm already chosen.
I know who I am.
I know what you've spoken.
I'm already love
more than I can imagine.
That is enough.
[Applause]
[Music]
That is enough.
You are gyro.
You are enough.
Child of you are love
and I will be content
in every circumstance.
Gyro
you are enough.
[Music]
>> Gy
you are enough.
And we will feast in the house of Zion.
We will sing with our hearts restored.
He has done great things. We will say to
together,
we will feast
and weep no more.
God, thank you that you have valued us
so much that we can trust you with the
little things and we can trust you with
the big.
that you are going to care for us. You
are going to walk with us,
that you will be our shelter in times of
trouble,
that you will be our rock and our
anchor.
[Music]
And God, any of the voices in our head
that have brought on thoughts of being
devalued or belittled or less than, God,
I pray that tonight we would hear your
voice
over us.
That says, "How much more do I value
you?
How much more
does your father love you? How much more
does he care for you?
[Music]
And would we remember God even in the
rocky times, in the times of trouble and
distress, that you will be enough.
Your presence will sustain us. Your
faithfulness will be with us.
It will uphold us.
God, would we remember your promises
and that you are a God who has kept your
word.
[Music]
God, would we listen for your voice?
Would we learn to tune into it, to
follow it, let your spirit guide us?
We love you and we ask God that you
would keep speaking in Jesus name. Amen.
All right, you guys can be seated. And
as you do, would you turn to the people
on either side of you and say, "The
peace of Christ be with you.
Grace and peace. Good to be with you
all. So, so good.
And uh yeah, just want to welcome you.
Welcome you into this space. And as
always, that um includes those joining
us online. Y'all are not forgotten.
Grateful for your uh your presence
through the wonders of the internets.
And uh don't forget to get your
communion elements for later in the
service. Um and uh also anyone here
who's new, we're really glad that you're
you're among us. So, um, let's see. This
is week two in our series titled
Cultivating Calm, staying centered in
difficult times. And,
you know, I mean, I feel like I don't
know, maybe it's just me. It it feels
like we're in a, you know, a kind of
season, a time of of pretty high stress.
And maybe some of that's just the modern
world with its all its technologies and
it's just sort of change change change
change change change change change
change change change change change ch
change you know and it's kind of just
like okay I'm just trying to keep up you
know like you had this experience where
like you're out of a job for like a
while you know say maybe out of an
industry even for like a year and then
you come back and you're like oh you're
behind oh no we don't use that software
now it's on to that you know what I mean
like there's just this perpetual just go
go so that can kind of lead uh to some
anxiety and kind of uncensoredness and
kind of add to that all of the the
things politically going on scapegoating
the LGBTQ community, the wars and rumors
of wars and you know it's just uh kind
of chronic perpetual um even kind of e
economic stuff there's just you know
it's just a lot and then kind of add to
that of just you know our everyday
things even if we didn't live in the age
of you know techn technological change
or whatever uh just you know things like
worry for our kids you or worry about
our our partner or just we're just
anxious and you know life's uncertain
and can be really challenging. uh
there's there's financial pressures and
you know just it can be a lot and so in
that I think we can you know at times
the all the language of you know the the
peace of Christ and the joy of the Lord
you know it can just feel like a very
almost like nice platitudes to say you
know but we don't we can maybe find
ourselves wondering like how do I like
live into that how do I cultivate that
that's why if you've heard me preach at
all you know I'm like constantly quoting
uh like monks and nuns and monastic type
people and it's because I think they've
chosen a life where they're very
intentionally trying to cultivate these
things like in real ways. You mean not
just sort of lip service like oh yeah
that's nice theology we all agree but
have no idea what we're actually talking
about. You know what I mean? So um so in
this series we're kind of looking at
like okay how what are some things we
can be doing to actually cultivate you
know this in our hearts and minds and
lives. So, uh, the title of my message
tonight is get moving. Get moving. And
our, uh, first reading, we have kind of
two readings from scripture. The first
is the words of Christ in the Gospel of
Matthew chapter 7. Uh, this comes at the
very end of the sermon on the mount. And
it says this, therefore, anyone who
hears these words of mine and puts them
into practice is like a a wise man who
built his house on the rock. The rain
came down, the streams rose, the winds
blew, and beat against that house. Yet
it did not fall because it had its
foundation on the rock. But everyone who
hears these words of mine and does not
put them into practice is like a foolish
man who built his house on sand. That
would be foolish indeed. You ever been
to the ocean? You're like, "Let's just
build a house here. No foundation,
though. We'll just kind of put up some
some wood. We'll just kind of drive it
into the sand. This should go well." You
know, um I remember we went on a mission
trip to Mexico way back when I was in
like junior high. We spent like all week
building this fence into sand and then
at the end of the week it just
fell over. You know we were foolish
people you know like we are not
following Jesus words here. So the rain
came down the streams rose the winds
blew and beat against that house and it
fell with a great crash. Uh second
reading you'll hear the probably some of
the connections with the the thematic
connections is this is James 1:es 19-22.
My dear brothers and sisters take note
of this. Everyone should be quick to
listen,
slow to speak, and slow to become angry.
There's like a whole other sermon in
that one. That's a good that's a good
word, you know, because human anger does
not produce the righteousness that God
desires.
I think that's kind of naming. Anger's
tricky,
you know. It's like there can be a
righteous anger, but woo, narrow is the
path and few find it. You know what I
mean? Like it's tricky. I just came up
with that on the spot. That was pretty
good. That was like not the spirit is
speaking. I don't know what's
um he continues, therefore get rid of
all moral filth and the evil that is so
prevalent and humbly accept the word
planted in you which can save you. And
this is like our key verse. Do not
merely listen to the word and so deceive
yourselves. Do what it says.
So, every morning like uh 6:00 a.m. or
so,
I I wake up. I tend to be an early riser
and uh it's it's maybe, you know, few
minutes before my alarm goes off, but uh
this is my time. You know what I mean?
This is my time. And I I lay there and I
uh almost without fail, I can't help but
spend like 5 to 10 minutes each morning
just thinking.
thinking probably sounds a little too
productive. Almost helpful. It's not
helpful. It's like I spend about 10
minutes just worrying like just running
through my day and like upcoming
meetings. Maybe I'm like a little bit
anxious about uh dreading whatever
workout I'm supposed to do. you know,
I've been doing it for years, but I
still lay there just like, you know,
and just kind of running through these
things like I'm used even on not even
just about the day like I'm used on huge
problems
that I am utterly incapable of solving.
Problems like what will the stock market
do in the next one to three years?
So stupid. Why am I not a better father?
I wish I was making more progress in
life.
What even is progress?
You know, just running through these
things. And so it continues until about
6:10 a.m. At which point I have
sufficiently to steal a line from the
wonderful writer David Dave Bentley
Hart. sufficiently flogged and whipped
the poor lumbering beast of my internal
will enough that I finally slip out of
my covers and exit my bed. And here's
the crazy part. Like within minutes
of getting up and moving forward,
somehow these demons that so haunted me
just minutes before, I'm using demons
more metaphorically. Don't take me too
serious. Some of you are freaking out,
what demons? Okay. Uh but these these
these issues that were so big, you know,
like these actions that felt impossible
now feel like if not easy, at least
easier. like much easier.
I think maybe this affliction is worse
for me as someone whose ego has
manifested in this world as an inagram
five. If that means nothing to you, just
know anyagram fives. We love thinking,
thinking, thinking, thinking, thinking,
thinking. And you know, at its best,
like I can kind of do that proactively,
like, oh, there's a problem to solve.
Let me like think this through, you
know, whatever. Uh, but you know, at its
worst, it's just it's just awful. Like
people have given this various names
throughout history. Like maybe analysis
paralysis is like one kind of classic
one, you know, just thinking in circles,
spinning my wheels. Like that's totally
me. Like I will just ruminate on a thing
for like months and months. just
thinking about it. Thinking about it,
you know, and I'm like that uh like that
little spinning circle that jumps up on
like apps or the internet when it's like
loading and it's just there and it's
just spinning, you know, like it's not
ready yet. Just loading. That's my
brain. But I'll just imagine if it did
that for months and you're just looking
at it like, huh, look at that thing. It
just keeps going. You know, that's
that's me just kind of spinning,
spinning, spinning. and the emotions of
fear and anxiety and anger and emotional
upset of every kind only make this
worse. We're probably all familiar with
the uh you know the kind of
psychological reactions we have to um to
danger, you know, like whenever a threat
to our well-being, you know, looms, some
people have the like fight response.
They're going to like fight it out and
someone has the flight. They're going to
run away, you know, whatever. Uh but my
favorite is uh the freeze one, you know,
where we're like a frightened rabbit.
We're just like, I don't know what to
do. So, I'm just not gonna do anything,
you know, I'm just gonna sit here and
think about it for a while, maybe a
year, you know, reflect on it, consider
it, analyze it from every angle. Why?
Well, you know, at least in my case, it
may be a little different for you, but
in my case, I just need more
information. Anyone an information
person? I need more information. Not
enough research. Never enough research.
Like, ever. It's just kind of freaking
endless, you know. And I'll just say
though, thank God like the wisdom of
previous generations has come down to us
through the uh through the scriptures
and it's really placed the emphasis
somewhere else like because you can find
of course in the scriptures like plenty
of theologizing I think of like the book
of Romans comes to mind uh even parts of
like John's gospel.
But on the whole like if you kind of
come to the scripture expecting like a
lecture in systematic theology
you'll like prepare to be a little
disappointed you know like wait where's
the long philosophical treatises you
know or well it's not it's not really
like that. Instead, what you have is
like a bunch of like story and history
and some poetry.
And then there's just a tremendous
emphasis on like living, you know, on
like literally just what you are to do.
This brings us back to Matthew 7, uh,
the passage we read earlier where, as I
mentioned, that comes at the the end of
the what's known as the sermon on the
the mount. And I want to give you, so
the sermon on the mountain is like three
chapters, five, six, seven. I want to
give you the headings for that instead
of like reading the whole thing. That'd
be a little laborious. But let me just
give you the chapter headings for me or
the um yeah the kind of headings in
there. Um and just kind of tune into how
like you know this stuff is again this
is not a philosophical treatise like
this is like life stuff. So here's
chapter five anger, lust, divorce,
oaths, retaliation, loving enemies.
Here's chapter six, generosity, praying,
fasting, money, anxiety. Matthew 7,
judging others, the golden rule, which
is literally do unto others as you'd
have them do unto you. Right? And then
that brings us to the text we read about
the two people kind of building house on
the rock and the sand and the and
whoever hears these words of mine and
does what I say. Right? So everything we
just covered the teachings on anger and
lust and retaliation and loving enemies
and generosity and praying and fasting,
right? It's all this kind of doing
action. Whoever hears these words and
then like does the things well they're
like a wise person. Whoever hears these
words but it's like well that's all
interesting information but does nothing
with them. Oh, this is like a
foolishness, you know,
like in other words, at some point the
the rubber of ideas and concepts and
teachings must meet the road of our
lives.
And
Finley's got all the words tonight.
That's all right. Um, and James says in
the passage, the second passage we read,
he says much the same thing in slightly
different language, right? merely be a
listener, a thinker, an analyzer, a
contemplator of the word. What? Like do
it. Do it. You know,
in uh 1965, the there's a visual artist.
I say visual artist like he did like
lots of different types of of art. Um
his name was Saul uh Luitt and he wrote
a famous letter to his friend Eva Hess
who was a uh sculptor
and she was just going through this time
of really intense like self-doubt,
fear, uh analysis paralysis as we were
talking about earlier like it's that
kind of mode which of course plagues
artists right where they get in that
mode where it's just like you know
writer's block, creative block, whatever
but really it's applicable to all of us,
We've all been in that place of that
kind of like ah I just can't you know
and so
uh I so this so he writes this letter to
her kind of from one artist to another
you know now I this letter was recently
I think it was kind of published in like
a series like a book that was a
collection of Saul's letters um but it
was kind of popularized on the social
medias that's how I saw it from uh
Benedict Cumberbatch did this like kind
of presentation where he like read it
that's how I came across it and I just
thought like oh my god this portion so
I'm going to read do a portion of the
letter and I will say it did have a lot
of curse words so I've like substituted
some like gentler versions just given
our setting but maybe it'll make it even
more like silly or hokey I don't know so
he says this this is solit to Eva says
dear Eva it will be almost a month since
you wrote to me you have possibly
forgotten your state of mind I doubt it
though you seem the same as always and
being you hate every minute of it
don't learn to say bleep you to the
world once in a while. You have every
right to
just stop thinking,
worrying, looking over your shoulder,
wondering, doubting, fearing, hurting,
hoping for some easy way out.
Struggling, grasping, confusing,
itching, scratching, mumbling, bumbling,
grumbling, humbling, stumbling,
mumbling, rambling, gambling, tumbling,
scumbling, scrambling, hitching,
hatching, moaning, groaning, honing,
moaning, horse crapping, hair splitting,
nitpicking, pee pee, trickling, nose
sticking, booty gouging, eyeball poking,
finger pointing, alleyway sneaking, Long
waiting, small stepping, evil eyeing,
backcratching,
searching, perching, bismerching,
grinding, grinding, grinding away at
yourself.
Stop it
and just
do
just do the thing.
I think that's brilliant. Like, isn't
this us just sort of endlessly
ruminating, considering, arguing,
contemplating, questioning, having the
same freaking conversation a hundred
times in a row, just I really should,
they really should do that. Just talking
about it, processing it. Oh my gosh.
like to when none of that
>> none of that
will ultimately
lead to the outcome we're wanting. Not
to say there's not a place to process, a
time to contemplate. There is.
But as we know, oh, there's a danger
lurking there where we fall into the pit
he's describing.
I think to kind of sum it up, we could
say when we are stressed, overwhelmed,
or afraid,
our tendency is to freeze or avoid.
When actually meaningful action is the
key to restoring calm.
>> You see, when we get in that stressed,
overwhelmed, fearful state, what often
goes out the window is our sense of
agency. We touched on this last week,
right? our sense of power, our sense of
hey, the spirit is within you and you
can do a thing.
You can do multiple things. You know
what I mean? Like you got you can do
this. And that's what kind of flies out
the window. And instead when we get in
that mode, well, now we get in like
victim mode. You know what I mean? Not
just a moment where I've been victim at
times we really have been a victim or
you know what I mean? But I mean like an
identity we kind of adopt and take on,
you know, like this is who I am. This is
I'm powerless. What can I do? I there's
nothing I can do. You know, we get in
that mode and now we're helpless. Now
we're up a creek without a paddle, lost
with no way home. This, of course, is
the uh like the perfect sort of story
arc for um that cinematic masterpiece,
Happy Gilmore 2. Anyone seen
Who has seen Happy Gilmore 2? Oh, few
y'all. I tried. I made it so far almost
to the end. Um, but it's I mean, it's
unbelievable. All right, so for those
who missed it, here's kind of the So,
basically, after accidentally killing
his wife with one of his 400yard wicked
drives,
such a right from the beginning, I was
like, this is the plot. Like, this is
how it begins. Kills his wife by hitting
a long golf drive. Like, I was like,
okay, here we go. All right. So he does
this and what happens? Classic. He
retreats, right? He hauls himself away
in his home. He takes up drinking
heavily. Goalless, aimless, purposeless.
He rots. And it's not until he gets a
new purpose, right? We need something to
like drive this pitiful story forward.
And so he gets a new purpose where he
realizes like, oh, I want to send my
talented daughter to ballet school in
Paris, you know, and through that he
inadvertently uh ends up finding himself
again, right? And what's going on there?
What's the thing? Well, but what
happened? He found like new inspired
purposeful action.
And I think that's what I'm driving at,
right? Is like this is often what's
driving so much of our life. And when we
lack that kind of intrinsic like I'm
moving towards something, I'm I'm going
somewhere. I'm doing a thing. Once that
goes, it's like yikes. And I think this
is in many ways the kind of genius of of
Christian faith and even other religious
traditions like we I think in our minds
particularly with Christianity, we often
think it is all about belief. You know
what I mean? Like the doctrines. And I
do think that was became increasingly
true with Protestantism which for those
unfamiliar that's like the wing of the
church that we are that's our tradition
you that's our wing of Christianity. It
did become like really heavy about
beliefs and such but if you look at the
broader tradition really the emphasis um
is actually largely it's on the doing
you know it's on the living. Like even
take something like uh well I mean just
think of Matthew 5:6 and 7. You know
what I mean? It's like a good example
where it's just a bunch of like say the
prayers and fast and pay attention how
you're treating your enemies and you
know I mean again it's not quite what we
would expect Jesus like where's the
systematic theology and the doctrine of
the two natures of Christ or whatever
like it's not there. Instead it's a
bunch of like hey be in silence and fast
once in a while you know it's this this
different emphasis. Um, even take
something like prayer, which I think
from the outside looking in, um, may not
look like you're doing much as you sit
there, you know, with your eyes closed,
you know, uh, talking to God. But I
think honestly that's kind of a
perspective from someone who maybe
hasn't done much praying, right? Where
it's it because it can look sort of like
the helpless victim, you know, I can't
do anything.
So, I'm just praying. It's just a it's a
picture of my powerlessness, you know,
just I'm I'm I'm resorting to prayer,
you know. Um, and there's like kind of I
think the what kind of occurs to me is
actually though prayer can be a kind of
uh beautiful on-ramp
to doing
when you've reached a place where you
don't know what else to do. Like for
example, I'm uh I guess reaching
midlife. I have like people who I love
them and they used to love me. I don't
mean like my family or something like
you know friends like like broken
relationships now. You know what I mean?
You have some of those people in your
life where it's like it used to be so
close but not so much anymore and
there's like bad booab you know what I
mean? and and we've tried to like talk
it through or work this out or you know
if it's almost like this point like the
more I try to meddle or fix it like the
worse it gets you know so you're just
kind of like uh and it's weird though
because I still love these people I want
to like a part of my heart still wants
to reconcile with them and like I want
this to be good you know and I've
actually found that prayer
actually becomes like it is the thing I
can do when there is nothing I can do.
You know what I mean? Like in essence in
that moment where I'm really tempted to
feel like I'm just utterly powerless.
There is no way. There is literally
nothing. They have said don't speak to
me. You know what I mean? There what do
I do? You know that actually even
something like prayer which looks so
passive uh is this powerful on-ramp back
into doing back into like no one can
stop you from praying blessing over
another person. You know what I mean? No
one can stop you from praying the
flourishing and thriving and healing and
reconciliation and life and hope and you
know what I mean like and you can see
where all of a sudden even in the most
absolute dire of situations where it's
like there is nothing you can do even in
that moment prayer becomes this on-ramp
this path back into doing. I love the
way uh Richard Roar says this in
closing. He says, 'We don't think
ourselves into a new way of living. We
live ourselves into a new way of
thinking. It's a good word, right?
So, in closing, like here's the question
I think we need to be asking ourselves.
What action is Christ inviting me to
engage?
engage? And you may wonder like, well,
how do I go about, you know, doing that?
Um, we'll call this the chair method.
Here's what I want you to do. Everyone
go ahead and close your eyes.
And in your mind's eye, I want you to uh
just imagine that sitting across from
you in a chair is Jesus.
And then ask him, "If you were living my
life today,
what would you do next?"
If you were living my life today,
what would you do next?
>> And then listen for a word. Maybe an
image comes to mind. Some sort of
emotional nudge.
And then based on that, just commit to
like one tangible step you can take
within the next 24 hours.
You can go ahead and open your eyes.
You see, in this time, I think it's so
essential that we not slide into apathy,
despair, or as we named last week, fear.
We must discern what Christ is inviting
us to do and then boldly step into it.
In the name of the Father, the Son, and
the Holy Spirit. Amen.
So on the night Jesus was betrayed, he
had one final meal with his disciples.
And at that meal, he held the loaf of
bread and he broke it and he said, "Take
it and eat. This is my body. It's broken
for you." Then he held up the cup of
wine. He said, "Take it and drink. This
is my blood. It's shed for you. Whenever
you eat this bread, whenever you drink
this cup, remember me."
So that's the um the sacrament, the the
practice that we're engaging, the thing
we're doing as we seek to reenter
ourselves and ground ourselves in the
life, death, the resurrection of Jesus
Christ. Tonight, um we'll go about this
just in our normal way. We'll start here
at the front. We'll go row by row
forming one line here in the middle. We
practice an open table. So if you're
here tonight, you'd like to participate,
you are free to to do that. Just know
the red is wine, the white is grape
juice. And finally, you can just partake
whenever and however you'd like. Some
folks take immediately, some like to
come up and kneel at the front. Um, some
return to their seats to partake. So,
this is the table, not of the church,
but of the Lord. And it's made ready for
those who love him and for those who
want to love him more. So, come you who
have much faith and you who have little.
You who have been here often and you who
have not been here long. You who have
tried to follow and you who have failed,
come because it's the Lord Jesus himself
who invites you. And it's his will that
those who want to meet him should meet
him here. Come to the table.
[Music]
We're going to close with a song um that
Charles Kaiser actually sent to me and
um I had to look up the way to pronounce
the name. It's Latin. It's called
Sushipe.
Sushi, I think. Um but it's a prayer, an
ancient prayer by a saint. And I just
want to read these words to you real
quick that we're about to sing. Would
you take, Lord, and receive my liberty,
my memory, my understanding, my will,
all that I call my own, and give me only
your love and grace because that is
enough for me. Um, if you guys would
like to stand and sing this with us, you
are welcome to. It is a new song. If you
would rather sit and let this just be a
prayer that you allow to just sink into
your heart and mind as we close out this
evening. Um let this be our offering to
give all that we have, all that we are
to a God who is enough and will meet us
right there.
[Music]
Would
you take Lord and receive my liberty
my memory
understanding
and my will all that I call my
[Music]
Give
me
oh
[Music]
your loving grace.
>> Your loving grace.
>> That is enough.
[Music]
That is love
for
me.
[Music]
You have given all to me. To you, Lord,
I return
it.
Everything
belongs to you. Do
it what you will.
together
me.
Oh,
[Music]
your loving grace.
>> Your loving grace.
>> That is enough.
That is enough
[Music]
for
me.
[Music]
For
me.
[Music]
Thank you for joining us this evening.
Um, if this is your first time visiting,
um, we'd love to hear from you. Um, you
can do that by, uh, filling out a card
at the little table over on the way out,
or you can do it scanning the QR code.
as you can do most of the things I'm
going to mention here in the next few
minutes. Uh the QR code will be the key
to all of those things. Um so um please
let us know you here. We'd love to get
to know you better. Um if you call the
table a home and you don't currently
serve on a ministry team, we would love
to have you join us up here or in the
back in the quiet of the sound booth or
in the children's ministry or somewhere
you'd feel appropriate. So um you can do
that via the QR code as well. So, please
join us. And there's a lot of cool
people up here. I do not feel as cool as
all these people, but it's a cool place
to be. Um,
last giving. Generosity is a key aspect
of life and adoration here at the table.
If you feel um compelled or well, not
compelled, but you feel motivated to do
so, uh you can do so at the small table
on your way out or with the QR code. As
I said, the key to everything here. Um,
so please feel free to uh do as your
heart leads you. Um, if you don't mind,
I'd like to end the night by giving you
a benediction and sending you out into
the week. So, if you can put yourself in
a posture of receiving, however that is
for you,
you are a child of God.
You are a child of God. This is true on
your best day and it's true on your
worst day. So as you go into your week
ahead with the yetto beet determined
highs and lows and everything in
between, go filled with the assurance
that you are loved, you are worthy, and
you are accepted just as you are.
Go filled with God's Holy Spirit and the
desire to extend these same gifts and
grace and unconditional love to everyone
you come in contact with. Be blessed and
we'll see you here next Sunday.
[Music]
Give
me
[Music]
only
your loving grace.
[Music]
Your love and grace
>> that is enough.
>> That is enough.